ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW LOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER A HIM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN CG THE
SYRIAN QUINN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
BOOKS SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
C. R. TO SMITH STONE TAKING
BELLA THERE IS V. APPROVED WELL
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. IMAM YASIR KHAN IMAM
YES SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
TAKE OUR HEARTS LORD AND DRAW
THEM CLOSER TO YOU. MAY THE
PEACE YOU HAVE PLACED WITHIN
OUR HEARTS MAKERS SUCH PEOPLE
THAT'S SPREAD PEACE WHEREVER
YOU GO. USE US ON THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR TO MAKE THIS WORLD A MORE
PEACEFUL PLACE IN YU WE TRUST
NOW AND FOREVER I MEAN. THANK
YOU MA'AM YES SIR WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
CHOW EIGHTY THREE YEAR. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
SAN JUAN. INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND ALL THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
SCHUMER SACRAMENTO THURSDAY
JUNE TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY REDDIT
NINETY M. THE HONORABLE REBEKAH
BARRICADE HANNAH SYSTEM SPEAKER
PRO TEMPORE THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING TO FUNCTION PROPERLY
DESK READING FOR DAVID ON THE
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL WAS
CALLED ASSEMBLY MEMBER MADE
CHANGES TO HER SHALL MOVES AND
MISTER FLORA SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AMPUTATIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALLADARES FOR
MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
BENNETT BRIAN CERVANTES MCCARTY
DAVIES AND WHEN. MISTER CHOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW GUEST
ON THE FLOOR FOR THE ASSEMBLY
FELLOWS RECOGNITION TODAY AND
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER SEATTLE
AND BURKE TO HAVE GUESTS SEATED
AT THEIR DESKS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS LACKEY
COOLEY CALDERON COOPER AND
GABRIEL TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT REALLY SIXTY TWO EIGHT.
THE FINAL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE SB SIX
THIRTY ONE PORTANTINO FOR THEIR
HEARING ON THURSDAY AUGUST.
TWENTY SIX. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE SIR WE WITHHOLDING
ASKINS IN ASTRAL CALL VOTE. MR
FLOOR AS WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS
CONSENT.
MISTER CHOW'S ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE MR FLOOR NO.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL EYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS THIRTEEN. THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS BACK AND HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION. TODAY WE RECOGNIZE
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE CLASS OF ASSEMBLY FELLOWS
THEIR FELLOWSHIP YEAR IS LIKE
NO OTHER DUE TO THE UNIQUE WORK
CONDITIONS THEY HAVE ENTERED
DUE TO THE COLD IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC DURING THEIR ELEVEN
MONTH TENURE WITH US THE
ASSEMBLY FELLOWS HAVE SERVED US
IN A WIDE RANGE OF STAFF
FUNCTIONS NEARLY HALF OF THE
OFFICES IN THE LEGISLATURE
EMPLOYEE FORMER FELLOWS FROM
THE EXECUTIVE JUDICIAL SENATE
OR ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP PROGRAMS
OTHER FORMER FELLOWS ARE NOW
MEMBERS ARE OFFICERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES. UNIVERSITY
INSTRUCTORS EXECUTIVES OR
COMMUNITY LEADERS THEY GO ON TO
DO GREAT THINGS THE FELLOWS ARE
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
POLICE I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. JESSE MARVIN UNRUH
ASSEMBLY FELLOWS AND THE
CORPORATE. FROM THE OFFICE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY
IS BROOKE PRITCHARD SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS. FROM THE
OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BARRICADE HANNAH SARAH GOODMAN
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF STANFORD
UNIVERSITY. FROM THE OFFICE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT IS
ALCHEMY GRAHAM HE IS A GRADUATE
OF UC DAVIS. FROM THE OFFICE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IS ALISA
BROOKS SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UC
BERKELEY. FROM THE OFFICE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON IS
MELISSA SANGHAM SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF UC RIVERSIDE. FROM
THE OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN IS IZZY SWIMMER SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF WILLIAM JESSUP
UNIVERSITY. FROM THE OFFICE OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU IS
HERSH GUPTA IS A GRADUATE OF
YALE UNIVERSITY. FROM THE
OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
IS EMMA MANOUKIAN SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF CAT CAL POLY SAN
LUIS OBISPO. IN THE. FROM THE
OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER IS WHY IT JUNE THE
TEN HE IS A GRADUATE OF
CALIFORNIA MARITIME ACADEMY.
FROM THE OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA IS JOSE
SANCHEZ HE IS A GRADUATE OF UC
DAVIS. FROM THE OFFICE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON IS
BRIANNA LEONE SHE IS A GRADUATE
OF SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY.
FROM THE OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN IS MARGARET LEE
SHE IS A GRADUATE OF UC SAN
DIEGO. FROM THE OFFICE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER IS
NATALIE R. GARCIA SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF UC RIVERSIDE. FROM
THE OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAY IS A CYNTHIA GOMEZ SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY. FROM
THE OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS IS KENNETH CRUZ HE IS A
GRADUATE OF UC BERKELEY. FROM
THE OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO IS REBEKAH AYALA SHE
IS A GRADUATE OF CLAREMONT
MCKENNA COLLEGE. FROM THE
OFFICE OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
IS MARIA MORALIS SHE IS A
GRADUATE OF USC. UNABLE TO
ATTEND TODAY'S SESSION TODAY IS
ADAM YANG HE SERVED IN THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS OF OFFICE
POLICY AND BUDGET HE IS A
<c.cyan>RADUATE OF POMONA COLLEGE.</c>
MEMBERS A BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE
FOR ALL OF OUR ASSEMBLY HELLO.
MEMBERS PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE GALLERY WE
WANT TO WELCOME OTHERS WHO ARE
PRESENT TODAY WE WELCOME THE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AT SACRAMENTO ROBERT
NELSON. AS WELL AS THE
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND ADVOCACY FOR
CSU SACRAMENTO NAY THIN
DIETRICH. THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDIES LEONORE E.
LAYING. THE DIRECTOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
AMBER CARLISLE SALGUERO. AND
COORDINATOR MARIANA DS. WE ALSO
WELCOME THE PARENTS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS OF THE FELLOWS WHO HAVE
JOINED US IN THE GALLERY. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. IN CLOSING
WE HAVE NO DOUBT THAT THIS
CLASS OF FELLOWS WILL CONTINUE
THE PROGRAM'S LEGACY OF
ACHIEVEMENT AND THIS CONCLUDES
OUR RECOGNITION.
MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO BE MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. SECOND
READING KERKORIAN. SENATE BILL
891-435-3173. TWENTY THREE
THREE TWENTY SIX THREE SIXTY TO
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT FORTY FOUR
FIVE HUNDRED FIVE OH THREE FIVE
THIRTY ONE FIVE FIFTY SIX SIX
SIXTY FOUR SEVEN HUNDRED SEVEN
TWELVE SEVEN FOURTEEN.
417-282-3230 1-283-235-2380
640-049-4344 NINETY SEVEN FIVE
ONE NINE FIVE FORTY ONE. FIVE
FORTY NINE SIX FOURTEEN SIX
SIXTY ONE SEVEN FIFTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN EIGHT NINETEEN
AND TWENTY SIX CENTS AN ABILITY
TWENTY SEVEN. ALL AMENDMENTS IN
COMMITTEE REPORTS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND DEEMED ADOPTED.
ADD MISTER CHOW YOU WERE AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF US ASSEMBLY MEMBER URBAN
PLEASE REMOVE SB FOUR OH NINE
COLLATERAL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL NOW
ALSO AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE SB THREE
TWENTY EGGMAN FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CLERK WILL AGAIN NOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WE
HAVE A NUMBER CONCURRENCE ITEMS
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY. THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE. A. B. TEN
SEVENTY NINE AND THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AN ACT RELATING TO
TRUSTS MR GALLAGHER YOU MAY
OPEN. YES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- AB TEN
SEVENTY NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE WHERE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THINK IT WAS
GALLAGHER SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CARCLUB IN THE ROLL
CALL MEMBERS UNDESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. IT IS OUT OF
THOSE. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
TWO AB ELEVEN FORTY THREE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN AND ACTUALLY IN THE
CIVIL PROCEDURE. MR BERMAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES NO VICTIM OF
HARASSMENT SHOULD BE DENIED A
PROTECTION ORDER SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEIR PERPETRATOR COULD NOT BE
FOUND. BUT THAT'S WHAT CAN
HAPPEN IN THE CASE OF CIVIL
HARASSMENT. AB ELEVEN FORTY
THREE WOULD AUTHORIZE A COURT
ORDER ALL TURN ALTERNATE MEANS
OF SERVICE IF THE RESPONDENT
CANNOT BE LOCATED OR IS EVADING
SERVICE. SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE PROCESS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE BY VICTIM IS
SEEK ALTERNATIVE SERVICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THINGS BERMAN. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE B. TWO SEVENTY
FIVE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA AND
ACTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
EMPLOYEES MR MEDINA EMAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS MEDINA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. THERE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE DEVELOPED
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRABLE.
WELL CULTURAL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY THREE KNOWS FOR SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCORDANT. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR SB SIX
THIRTY EIGHT CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KIRK SILVA AND
OTHERS AN APPLE IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE MS
CLARK SILVA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB SIX THIRTY EIGHT
BUILDS UPON LAST YEAR STRIDES
BY AUTHORIZING COUNTIES TO
INCLUDE IN THEIR PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION COMPONENT
MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL AS
SUBSTANCE MISUSE OR CO
OCCURRING SUBSTANCE. USE
DISORDER NEEDS I RESPECTFULLY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS IT IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOTHES ARE TIDE OF
AN I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE
ACR NINETY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
HEALTHY HOMES AWARENESS MONTH
MISTER CHIP. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES ARE SIMPLY
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED ACR NINETY
ONE TO DECLARE HEALTHY HOMES
MONTH THE MINUTES FOR MADE IN
THE SENATE TO ADD ADDITIONAL
DATA NOW IT'S BACK IN
CONCURRENCE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
ISSUE SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY SIX AB
FOUR FOUR FIVE FIVE MISS
CALDERON CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
ACCOLADES FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES THIS CALDERON YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FORTY FIVE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE CLARIFYING AND
REQUESTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS C. NOTIFICATION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF IT. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY ONE OH ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONVERTED
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN IS AB SIX
EIGHTY NINE CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND OTHERS I APPLING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. MISPRISION
OURS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY NINE
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
MODERNIZES DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOTLINE SERVICES TO INCLUDE
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS CHAT AND-
AND MESSAGING I THE EXPANSION
OF THE SERVICES WILL ENSURE
THAT MORE PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO
GET HELP MORE QUICKLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CARCLUB THE ROLE MEMBERS. IT IS
ART ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE THAT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHT THE CORKERY. SYMBOL SIX
NINETY EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS AND ALCALINA
HAZARDOUS WASTES DR COURT FROM
MS REYES DESK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SPEAKER
IN MEMBERS AB SIX NINETY EIGHT
IS COMMITTEE BILL SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CHAPTER IN
ISSUES THERE IS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
CONCURRENCE IN SEVEN MINUTES
THANK YOU THEY GET A QUICK
SENIOR DISCUSSION BATES CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN A FILE
ITEM FORTY NINE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY AB TEN SIXTY ONE BY
MR LEE CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE MOBILE HOMES. MR
LEE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TEN SIXTY ONE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE OF WORK
TEXT AND MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS
FROM UNFAIR WATER SERVICE
CHARGES THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT MOBILE HOME PARKS.
CAN RECOVER COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PARK WATER SYSTEM
THROUGH OTHER MEANS THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT MOBILE HOME
PARK OWNERS ARE NOT
PROFITEERING OFF OF PROVIDING
THEIR RESIDENTS WITH WATER. AB
TEN SIXTY ONE RECEIVED TWENTY
SEVEN AYE VOTES IN THE SENATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BILL FOR CONCURRENCE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CARPAL OF
THE ROLE MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE
TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE ROLE TIDE
OF THE EYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. IN FILE ORDER
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE. AB
ELEVEN OH ONE AND THE COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN A ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AN
ACCOLADE IN THE COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS BIZARRE WHEN YOU
MAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN A ONE IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
OF WILL PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY ON EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS IN CALIFORNIA-
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE ENSURE
THAT HOAS OF ALL SIZES BOTH IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF UNITS
AND THEIR OPERATING BUDGETS ARE
TRANSPARENT. AND THAT THERE
TRANSIT IT WITH THEIR
TRANSACTIONS AND WILL
EFFECTIVELY SAFEGUARD FUNDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL I THINK
IT IS IRWIN SENIOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE CARPAL OF THE ROLE
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT THIS IS FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO AB THIRTEEN OH FIVE
AYE MR LACKEY FOR COREY
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY AN
ACCOLADE IN THE CANNABIS. MR
LACKEY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB THIRTEEN OH FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
WERE SUGGESTED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. TO ALLOW THE
STATE TO GROW ITS OWN CANNABIS
FOR RESEARCH AND IT'S A
SENSIBLE MEASURE THE DESERVES
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU HER NAME
IS LACKING I SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CLERK WILL OF THE
ROLE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSEROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE A. J. R. FOURTEEN. IN THE
QORQORI ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO TITLE NINE
IS BOERNER HORVATH YES THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AJ
ARE FOURTEEN WITH HONOR THE
FORTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF
TITLE NINE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
SEX BASED DISCRIMINATION IN OUR
SCHOOLS I WOULD URGE
CALIFORNIANS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE ITS
GOALS OF MORE EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU. TITLE
NINE IS A CIVIL RIGHTS LAW THAT
ALL ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
SCHOOLS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
RECEIVING FEDERAL FUNDING MUST
COMPLY WITH THIS LAW HAS BEEN
CRITICAL IN FOSTERING THE
SUCCESS OF YOUNG WOMEN FOR THE
PAST FORTY NINE YEARS. THE
PROMISE OF TITLE NINE IS THAT
IT GUARANTEES EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY FOR EVERYONE REGARDLESS
OF SEX GENDER IDENTITY OR
GENDEREXPRESSION WELL THIS LAW
HAS INCREASED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
GIRLS AND WOMEN IN ACADEMIC
SPORTS AND OTHER EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES IT IS NOT YET
ACHIEVED THE GOAL OF FULL
EQUALITY AS YOU ARE FOURTEEN
RECOGNIZES THE STRIDES THAT
WE'VE MADE SINCE TITLE NINE IS
BECOME LAW AND URGES US TO
CONTINUE OUR FIGHT FOR EQUAL
OPPORTUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
IS BOERNER HORVATH. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLARK WELL
OVER THE ROLE MEMBERS THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IT IS OUT OF A CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY EIGHT
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS IN
FILE ORDER FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR
IS AB THREE FIFTY EIGHT BY
MISTER FLORA CORKERY. SYMBOL
THREE FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLOOR AND OTHERS IN
THEIR FAILINGS OF ELECTRIFIED
SECURITY FENCES MISTER FLORES.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THREE FIFTIES BACK ON
CONCURRENCE IN THE MOMENT TO
MOMENT OUR TECHNICAL. MAKE
FURTHER CLARIFICATIONS OF
RECEIVING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANKS
FOR SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR ALL IT IS
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESERT ABOUT. CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PAST RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE. FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX IS AB EIGHT OH THREE.
BY MS BERNARDA. KERKORIAN
ASSEMBLY BILL IT'LL THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
AND OTHERS IMMACULATE INTO LAND
USE THIS BOERNER HORVATH MISTER
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ZERO
THREE IS THE STARTER HOME
REVITALIZATION AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND A SIX TO ADDRESS
THE MISSING MIDDLE OF OUR
HOUSING CRISIS THERE WERE
SENATE AMENDMENTS AND THEY
SPECIFIC SPECIFIED THAT A CITY
OR COUNTY MUST APPROVE AN
APPLICATION FOR QUALIFYING
DEVELOPMENT UNLESS THE FUNDS
THE DEVELOPMENT DOES NOT MEET
THE- REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL.
CLARIFIED THAT THE MINIMUM
DENSITY OF QUALIFYING
DEVELOPMENTS IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES AND REMOVE THE
PROHIBITION OF LOCAL AGENCIES
TO IMPOSE PARKING CONTROLS ON
QUALIFYING DEVELOPMENTS THAT
ARE LOCATED WITHIN A HALF A
MILE MAJOR TRANSISTOR BASICALLY
IT SAYS NO HOMES FOR CARS WITH
CITIES COULD STILL HAVE THEIR
NORMAL PARKING REQUIREMENTS
THIS BILL HAS. ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONFERENCE THANK YOU IS
BOERNER HORVATH SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE REMOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIDE OF
I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE OUT OF FIFTY SEVEN
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY BY MR
RODRIGUEZ CORPORATE SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND ACCOLADES
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT THIS
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B. FOURTEEN
IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE A. B. FOURTEEN
ANYWHERE PERMIT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO REQUEST AND RECEIVE
ARREST INFORMATION FOR SPECIFIC
NON SWORN EMPLOYEES. AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY NARAL THE REST OR
DETENTION SUBJECT TO DISCLOSURE
TO SERIOUS AND BELT VIOLENT
FELONIES AS WELL AS CRIMES
INVOLVING DISHONESTY OR
OBSTRUCTION OF LEGAL PROCESS.
FOR ADDRESS WROTE THANK YOU
MISS RODRIGUEZ C. NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS.
WHAT IS OUT OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF HER DESIRE TO VOTE THE CLERK
WILL CLOSER ALL TIRED BUT I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS R. CONCURRED IN.
HEY
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY PLEASE
REMOVE SB THREE EIGHTY SIX
NUMBER. FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
HI THERE IS A RULES COMMITTEE
RESOLUTION AT THE DESK TO
SUSPEND JOINT ROUTE SIXTY ONE I
ASK THAT WE GO TO THAT ITEM NOW.
THE CLERK WILL READ RESOLVE THE
JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE EIGHTY BE
SUSPENDED TO PREVENT THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO MEET
CONSIDER AND REPORT CYNICAL
THREE THIRTY FOR FURTHER ACTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED. THERE IS WILL TAKE
A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE JOINT
RULE SIXTY ONE RESOLUTION CLARK
WELL OVER THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THIS IS PROCEDURAL MEASURE
CHAO'S ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE TITLEIST
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS FOURTEEN.
JOINT ROLE IS SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP THE AMENDMENTS. THAT
ARE PRESENT ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE WE'RE GOING TO
AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. BEGINNING WITH
FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN. THIS IS
SB SIXTY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT AND CARPOOL
REQUIREMENTS SENATE BILL SIXTY
WITHIN MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN MISTER
pSPEAKER THESE AMENDMENTS MERELY
HAD AN URGENCY CLAUSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THEY RESPECT HANDS SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS
UP TO PRINTED BACK ON FILE. AND
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO. FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE FILE ITEM NINETY ONE.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ
WITH AMENDMENT SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU MISTER
CHILL ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
APPROVAL HAVE CHECKED
AMENDMENTS FOR SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY ON BEHALF OF
CENTER CORTESE TO ENSURE NO
IMPACT ON ANOTHER BILL THAT WAS
SIGNED EARLIER THIS YEAR BY THE
GOVERNOR WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
MR CHIU WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED AND THE
BILL SUCH PRINTED BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE THE
TOP OF THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
FIFTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE AND
SIXTY. IN A FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM. SIXTY ONE. HR FIFTY
TWO. BY DR CHOI AND THE CLERK
WILL READ HOUSE RESOLUTION
FIFTY TWO BIASED MEMBER CHOI
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO CONSIDER
DR CHOI YOUR MAILBOX THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS IT
IS A MARIANO TO RISE 2% OF
HOMES WERE SOLUTION FIFTY TWO
WHICH WILL DECLARE ON NOVEMBER
TWENTY SECOND NOW AND- THEY
WERE AFTER US A KIMCHI DAY IN
CALIFORNIA MAKING THIS YEAR TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AS THEIR
FIRST EVER. CALIFORNIA OCT IN
TODAY EVERY YEAR IN SOUTH KOREA
JIM TODAY IS CELEBRATED ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY SECOND LOP OFF
NOVEMBER ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
SECOND- ARM BECAUSE THEY IT TO
REPRESENTS SAW ELEVEN PORTAL
INGREDIENTS AWFUL KIMCHI AND
THE TWENTY TOOL HEALTH THE
BENEFITS ALL OF OUR COMMITTEE
THIS RESOLUTION IS SAW JOINT
THE AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHOWING CONSERVE OUR AND THE
CALL AUTHORED BY OF OUR
COLLEAGUE KARA AND THE SENATE
SENATOR DAVID MILLION KIMCHI AS
SALT MORE THAN JUST OF
VEGETABLES SO PREPARED TO. WITH
THE VARIETY OF LOSSES INNINGS
SO IF EMBODIES SO THE IDENTITY
OF KOREA KIM JONG THE
TRADITIONAL TRADITIONAL OF A
MAKING SEVENTY BROUGHT TOGETHER
THE ENTIRE VILLAGES SOUGHT AND
THE NEIGHBORHOOD SO TO TURN
HUNTERS OF OUR HEADS ALL OF THE
CABBAGES ARE AND TO HE'S ALSO
SOLVE OUR FOOD AND THE
NUTRITION FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
HISTORICALLY OF WARM MOMENT IN
A ROW SO OF ALL THE FREE BASIN
AND THE STARVATION MANY OF ALL
OF THIS ON YOUR CHURCH
NUTRIENTS REPORTEDLY CAN
CONTRIBUTE TO A LOWER RATES OF
A STROKE CANCER DIABETICS AND
THE HEART DISEASE AND NOT TO
IN. ERIN DOT TO INCREASE THE
IMMUNITY AND- DURING THIS SO
CALLED ME NINETEEN THIRTEEN SHE
HAS BECOME VERY POPULAR BECAUSE
SAW IT IS US WELL PROVEN IN
MANY WAYS SO IN PREVENTION AND
ALSO FEWER BETWEEN. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWELVE AND THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN KOREAN
CUISINE SO 34% INCREASE ALL
ONLINE AND THE 45% OF THE
PEOPLE WERE WERE INTERESTED IN
TRYING KOREAN CUISINE THIS LED
TO ONE INCREASING DEMAND FOR
KIMCHI AND A KOREAN FOOD ARE IN
THE U. S. SPECIFICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA SO ALL MAJOR
RETAILERS SAW NONG JERRY HIM
TO. IN ADDITION TO IZHAR FIFTY
TWO TODAY THEY'RE ALL FULL OF
THE- KOREAN RESOLUTION SO
PASSING OFF THE- CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY POST ON ON TIME
ALL DAY I DID ON DAY KOREAN
INDEPENDENCE DAY AND AKAN THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE FIRST EVER
KOREAN WAR MEMORIAL MONUMENT.
ARE BEING BUILT ALL IN
FULLERTON ARE IN FACT THAT THAT
IS THE ONLY ONE IN THE UNITED
STATES SO THAT WERE INSCRIBED
ALTHOUGH ARE SACRIFICED A
MEMBERS ALL OF YOUR SOLDIERS
SET UP WOULD. BE IN FULLERTON
ORANGE COUNTY AREN'T AND SAW
ARE WE HAVE A VERY LIMITED THE
GAS STILL- WE BECAUSE OF A
PANDEMIC WE COULD NOT INVITE
THEM- TO THE FLOOR AND DAHLE
ONLY EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF ALL THE PEOPLE
RIGHT NOW CELEBRATING WITH THE
L. R. MINIATURE OF KIMCHI
FESTIVAL AT THE HYATT HOTEL
ACROSS THE STREET. BUT THE ONLY
TWENTY PEOPLE ARE SPREAD OUT ON
THE BALCONY OUR SERVICE I DON'T
THINK I CAN INTRODUCE ALL OF
THEM BUT THE NOTABLY LOS
ANGELES A CONSUL GENERAL
POPULATION J. AND THE SOME
FRIENDS CISCO A CONSUL GENERAL
UNIONS HUNG SO. ESPECIALLY ON
THE CAST OF A DEPUTY SECRETARY
LEVEL OF OUR KOREAN- EVERY
CULTURE AND THE FISHERY AGENCY
CAN TURN CHEN WHO TRAVELED ALL
THE WAY FROM KOREA. THERE ARE
MANY OTHER PEOPLE OR WATCHING
ON TV IN THE ROOM R. FORTY R.
HELLO YOUR TRUE OUR AND THE I
WOULD LIKE TO I'LL GIVE THEM
WELCOME ALL WE EVER THEY ARE
OPEN TO BALCONY AND THE WHOLE
BIT READ EVER THEY ARE WATCHING
AND OF THIS IS A VERY SPECIAL
DAY AND ALLOW THE ASK YOU ALL
OF YOU TO JOIN ME- AND THE
SUPPORT HR FIFTY TWO.
DESIGNATING NOVEMBER TWENTY
SECOND. OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AS
THE FIRST SECOND TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA BY THE WAY. ARE
AFTER THE SESSION THE CAN TO
FESTIVAL WERE STILLBORN INDIA.
ARE HYATT HOTEL YOU'RE WELCOME
TO COME BY AND THE LOSS OF A
GOOD IS- PREPARE THE FOR YOU
AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK
YOU DR CHOI. M. MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT AND THANK THE
HONORABLE COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY FOR HOSTING ME TO ENJOY
A MEAL OVER SOME GOOD KIMCHI
AND A PERMISSION TO READ MISTER
SPEAKER WITHOUT OBJECTION- A
LETTER OF SUPPORT FROM THE
CREAM BARBECUE LEAGUE OF
GREATER LOS ANGELES. THE
FOUNDING CHAPTER OF THIS
NETWORK AND GROWING CREAM
BARBECUE LEAKS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE FOUNDING MEMBERS
RIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF H.
R. FIFTY TWO AN HONOR TO SEE
CALIFORNIA ONCE AGAIN LEAD THE
WAY IN CREE AND BARBECUE AS THE
GOLDEN STATE HAS DONE SO IN
MANY WAYS. IN MANY FIELDS OF
TECHNOLOGY AND AGRICULTURE THIS
LEAGUE IS FOUNDED UPON THE
IDEAL OF HIGHLIGHTING THE MANY
DELICACIES THAT THE CREAM
BARBECUE EXPERIENCE HAS TO
OFFER TO ENCOURAGE ATHLETES
YOUNG AND OLD ALIKE TO CONSUME
CREAM BARBECUE INCLUDING KIMCHI
AND A COMPETITIVE YET
RESPECTFUL MANNER. THIS FOSTERS
A SPIRIT THAT GIVES EVERYONE
ATTENDING IN APPRECIATION OF
EXPERIENCE AND CULTURE WHETHER
IT'S PART OF BOND JOHN OR MIXED
IN WITH DELICIOUS BROTH AS PART
OF G. GAVE HIM SHE OFTENTIMES
TOGETHER WITH THE ENTIRE CREAN
BARBECUE. EXPERIENCE. WITH THAT
SAID THERE IS A GROW MEMBERSHIP
OF CREAM BARBECUE AFFECTION
OWES HIM RESPECTFULLY PRIVATE
THANK YOU MR LOW AND MISS QUICK
SILVA YOU TOO ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE AS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF HOUSE RESOLUTION
FIFTY TWO WHICH RECOGNIZES AND
CELEBRATES ONE OF KOREA'S
TRADITIONAL STAPLE AND KOREAN
CAUSE CUISINE NO AND ASK HIM
SHE- I WANT TO WELCOME ALL OF
THE HONORABLE GUESTS THAT HAVE
TRAVELED HERE TO SACRAMENTO TO
CELEBRATE HIM DAY KIMCHI IS A
TRADITIONAL SIDE DISH EATEN
WITH ALMOST EVERY KOREAN MAIL
HIM SHE IS SALTED AND FERMENTED
VEGETABLES SUCH AS NAPA CABBAGE
AND KOREAN CAD RADISH MADE WITH
VARIAN SELECTIONS OF SEASONINGS
I HAD A CHANCE TO TRAVEL TO
ACTUALLY MAKE HIM SHE WAS SOME
OF THE BEST SPICES AND
TECHNIQUES KNOWN TO THE HOME OF
KOREANS. CALIFORNIA IS HOME
232% OF THE COUNTRY'S KOREAN
POPULATION AND I AM PROUD THAT
THE SIXTY FIFTH DISTRICT WHICH
I REPRESENT REPRESENTS THE
SECOND LARGEST KOREAN AND
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN THE
NATION IN ADDITION WE ARE MANY
NOT ONLY CREE AND RESTAURANTS
AND FULLER TEN BUT WE ARE HOME
OF THE LARGEST IMPORTS FOR
KOREAN FOOD NOW IN CALIFORNIA.
THE KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
HAS HAD AND CONTINUES TO RAGE
THE CULTURAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC LANDSCAPE OF THIS
GREAT STATE AND SOUTH KOREA
NOVEMBER TWENTY SECOND IS
CELEBRATED EVERY YEAR BY
DESIGNATED YOU KNOW AT AS KIM
SHE DAY. TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TROY AND I ARE HONORED TO BRING
THIS CELEBRATION TO CALIFORNIA
TO JOIN US AND ALL OF YOU AND
CELEBRATING HIM SHE EVERY YEAR
ON NOVEMBER TWENTY SECOND.
THANK YOU MISS CLARK SILVA SEE
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION DR CHOI GIVING
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK A CALL AUTHORS SO
WHICH TO JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS BILL AND- MAY I TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. TO JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING ALL THE GUESTS ARE IN
THIS BUILDING AND THE FRONT
DOOR OF ATTEMPTED BUILDING ALL
WHO HAVE TRAVELED UP TO CAPITOL
TO COMMEMORATE THAT IS A
WONDERFUL LOCATION OF WHAT
PASSES PASSAGE OPPORTUNITY OR
SOLUTION. LAST WELCOME THEM. A
DOCTOR CHOI IS ASKING THAT THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR A CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY
SIX CO AUTHORS ADDED ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION AND WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY
THE EYES HAVE IT THE HOUSE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. N. FILE
ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE A. C. R. ONE OH ONE.
COOKERY ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAY R. TWO AND OTHERS
RELATIVES. MR SAY ARE TELL YOU
MAIL ME THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO BRING
THIS RESOLUTION BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE SEPTEMBER
TWENTY FIFTH. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE AS CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTER MEMORIAL DAY HERE
ON THE STATE CAPITOL GROUNDS
STANDS OF FIREFIGHTERS MEMORIAL
MISTER SAY OR TELL MY APOLOGIES
SIR I READ THAT ITEM OUT OF
ORDER IF WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
UP THE FIREFIGHTER ITEM WE CAN
DO THAT AT THIS TIME. THAT'S MY
FAULT SIR MY APOLOGIES THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO. FILE ITEM
SIXTY TWO AC ARE TEN CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION TEN
BY SOME MEMBERS SAY OUR TOE
RELATIVES CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTER APPRECIATION MONTH
AND CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
MEMORIAL DAY THANK YOU SIR YOU
MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AS I HAD STATED BEFORE
YOU'RE ON THE STATE CAPITOL
GROUNDS STANDS THE FIREFIGHTERS
MEMORIAL WHICH BEARS THE NAMES
OF OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED MEN
AND WOMEN. WHO HAVE MADE THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE IN DEFENSE
OF OUR SAFETY. I KNOW TWENTY
EIGHT OF THOSE ARE MORE
COLLEAGUES OF MINE THESE
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE PASSED UNDER
TRAGIC CIRCUMSTANCES FROM
EITHER DANGEROUS NATURE OF THE
WORK. OR THE JOB OR FROM
ILLNESSES CAUSED AS A RESULT OF
HAZARDOUS WORKING CONDITIONS ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WE WILL
COMMEMORATE THE NINETEENTH
ANNUAL CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS
MEMORIAL CEREMONY HONORING
THEIR SACRIFICE. IT IS WITH
THIS IN MIND THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TO RECOGNIZE
SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AS
FIREFIGHTER MEMORIAL DAY AND
THE MONTH OF SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AS FIREFIGHTER
APPRECIATION. MONTH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR SAY ARE TELL
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE A. C. R. YES MR
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
WANT TO- I UNDERSTAND AND
ENJOYED WITH THE AUTHOR AND SO
MANY OTHERS IN OUR APPRECIATION
OF OUR FIREFIGHTERS ABOUT TEN
DAYS AGO SHARON AND I WALKED
OUT THE FRONT DOOR OF OUR HOME
AND LOOKED THREE HOUSES DOWN TO
SEE TO HOMES IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD IN GULF AND FIRE.
YOU KNOW YOU YOU THINK IT NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN TO YOUR NEARBY.
AND AS A MATTER FRESNO FOR
EIGHT YEARS. TO WATCH A THREE
ALARM FIRE AND TO SEE THESE
FIREFIGHTERS SHOW UP DO THEIR
DUTY BUT TO SEE IT UP CLOSE AND
TO SEE THE EXHAUSTION AND TO
SEE THE HELP THAT WAS GIVEN TO
THE FIREFIGHTERS. IT IS JUST A
REMINDER WE TAKE FOR GRANTED
WHAT THESE HEROES DO AND YOU
KNOW WE THROW THE WORD HERO
AROUND AN AWFUL LOT THESE DAYS
AB SOMETIMES IN SPORTS IT'S
HEROIC IF SOMEBODY SINKS A
BASKET AT THE TOP OF THE KEY
THREE POINTS TO WIN THE GAME
THAT'S GREAT IT'S WONDERFUL BUT
IT. I DON'T THINK IT RISES TO
HEROIC ROIC IS WHEN PEOPLE
RAISE THEIR RIGHT HAND AND THEY
SWEAR THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
PROTECT AND TO SERVE KNOWING
FULL WELL THAT IT MIGHT COST
THEM THEIR OWN LIFE SHARON AND
I SAW THAT UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL. AND I WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE NOT ONLY TO THE
FIREFIGHTERS IN FRESNO BUT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM UP AND
DOWN THE STATE PARTICULARLY
THOSE FIGHTING THESE EXPLOSIVE
WILDFIRES THANK YOU FOR RUNNING
TOWARDS THE FLAMES THANK YOU
FOR EXHAUSTING YOURSELVES FOR
SAFETY AND FOR SOMEONE ELSE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO SAFETY AND OTHERS UP WE ARE
VERY VERY GRATEFUL I THINK THE
RESOLUTION HERE BEFORE US
EXPRESSES THAT BUT I WANTED TO
RISE AND JUST SAY FROM THE
PATTERSON FAMILY AND FROM OTHER
GROUP OF HOMEOWNERS IN TILLMAN
AVENUE GOD BLESS YOU AND THANK
YOU AND THAT. PLEASE COME HOME
FROM DUTY SAFE ALIVE AND WELL
TO SERVE ANOTHER DAY GOD BLESS
YOU AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS PATTERSON MR GRAYSON YOU
TWO ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IT DOES GO
WITHOUT SAYING THAT THE LAST
FEW WILDFIRE SEASONS HAVE BEEN
SOME OF THE DEADLIEST IN OUR
HISTORY. OUR FIREFIGHTERS HAVE
CONTINUOUSLY DEMONSTRATED THEIR
COMMITMENT TO SERVE OVER SELF
AND- THESE TIMES- THAT THEY'RE
SERVING ARE AT THE AT THE
HIGHEST RISK ESPECIALLY IN
THESE WILDFIRE SEASONS AS WELL
AS IN OUR OWN COMMUNITIES
FACING HOUSE FIRES AND OTHER
AND OTHER DANGERS COVERED
NINETEEN ADDED. A WHOLE NEW
DIMENSION OF RISK TO THE JOB
BOTH ON AND OFF THE FRONT LINES
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WE CAN
THANK OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND UP
SO THANK YOU THE AUTHOR OF ACR
TEN AND- AND I WANT TO ALSO
BRING IN A POINT HERE THANK YOU
TO THE FAMILIES. OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS FOR THE SUPPORT
THAT THEY PROVIDE TO THE
FIREFIGHTERS SO THAT THEY CAN
DO WHAT THEY DO FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I JUST HOPE
THAT THIS RESOLUTION SERVES AS
A TOKEN OF OUR APPRECIATION AS
WEAK KNOWLEDGE OF HARD WORK
THAT THEY DO- AND YES THE HER
ROWING HARD WORK OF THESE WOMEN
AND THESE MEN. IN UNIFORM SO
WITH THAT I DO RISE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF ACR TO.
THANK YOU MISS GRACE AND MR
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR
TEN I THINK. NOW MORE THAN EVER
MEMBERS OF THE FIRES RAGING
THROUGH CALIFORNIA. WE MUST
REMEMBER THE ALL THE HARD WORK
THEY DO DAY IN AND DAY OUT NOT
JUST DURING THE FIRE SEASON
BALL ALL THE TIME. I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY WORK SIDE BY SIDE
SOME OF THESE FIREFIGHTERS AND
SEE ALL THE HARD WORK AND
EFFORT THEY DO. AND THE TIME
THEY SPEND AWAY FROM THEIR
FAMILIES DURING THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES WITH THE FIRES SO ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR. TEN AND
RECOGNIZING SEPTEMBER TWENTY
FIFTH THE FIREFIGHTER
APPRECIATION DAY THANK YOU MR
COOLEY YOUR RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I WANT TO RISE TODAY
JUST IN SUPPORT OF THIS ARE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THIS WEEK I
JUST WANT TO SHARE I WATCHED
ALL WEEKEND LONG AS AIRCRAFT OR
FIND IN AND OUT OF SACRAMENTO
SUPPORTED OUR FIREFIGHTERS IN
THE FIELD BIG L. TEN ELEVEN BIG
AIRCRAFT DROPPING FIRE THE
HERCULES AIRCRAFT DAY AND DAY I
HAD TO SEE THOSE FLIGHTS DOZENS
OF TIMES ALMOST EVERY FIVE
MINUTES YOU WOULD SEE THEM
LEAVING FROM A CALL OF MY
DISTRICT AND HEADED EAST TO
THIS FIRE AND THEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCE OF THAT FIRE I
HAVE A SON THAT LIVES UP THE
HILL. AND WE'VE DEALT WITH THE
INCONVENIENCE OF SMOKE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO BUT I'VE BEEN KIND
OF MONITOR QUALITY YOU KNOW SO
WE DON'T LIKE TO WANT TO GETS
OVER FIFTY BECAUSE IN ITS
MODERATELY BAD OVER A HUNDRED
SENSITIVE FOLKS POLLOCK PINES
ARE SURE WAYS UP HIGHWAY FIFTY
THIS MORNING. WAS AT NINE
FIFTY. UNIMAGINABLE SETTINGS.
WERE OUR FIREFIGHTERS ARE DOING
THEIR WORK ITSELF. AIRCRAFT ARE
NOT THE FIREFIGHTERS BOOTS ON
THE GROUND BUT I SHARE THAT
STORY BECAUSE IT CONVEYED TO ME
THE URGENCY OF THE BATTLE FIVE
OF THESE FIRES WHEN SO MANY
RESOURCES BEING BROUGHT TO BEAR
AND THEN THE ADVERSE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR THOSE ON THE
GROUND- THE VARIABLE WINDS THE
DIFFICULTY SEEING THE
REMOTENESS OF. GETTING IN TO
WHERE YOU CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE
I JUST THANK YOU MISTER CERTAIN
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MR SAY ARE TELL YOU
MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH I'D
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR KIND WORDS OF SUPPORT
FROM MY COLLEAGUES THAT ARE OUT
THERE ON THE FRONT LINES- THEY
ARE HAVING A PARTICULARLY
DIFFICULT SUMMER AWAY FROM
THEIR FAMILIES A LOT OF THEM.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AND WOULD LIKE THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. THANK YOU THE OTHER
GESTURE THAT THE VIRTUAL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR
ALL AUTHORS ON ACR TEN THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THERE ARE CLINICAL
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE. A. C. R.
ONE L. ONE. CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
A ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAY
ARTAUD AND OTHERS BOTH OF
CALIFORNIA MERCY PREPARE THIS
MONTH MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY
OPEN FROM YOUR DESK IT'S JUST
BIGGER MEMBERS. OUR TATE FACES
MULTIPLE EMERGENCIES EACH YEAR.
FLOODS WILDFIRES PANDEMICS
MUDSLIDES AND DROUGHTS AND MANY
MORE. ACR ONE ON ONE HIGHLIGHTS
THE IMPORTANCE OF PLANNING FOR
SUCH EMERGENCIES A PROCLAIMS
THE MONTH OF SEPTEMBER S.
CALIFORNIA MERGING PREPAREDNESS
MONTH. MERGING PROVIDERS MONTH
PROVIDES AN ANNUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO EDUCATE AND EMPOWER
CALIFORNIANS TO PREPARE FOR AND
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES AND TO
COMMEND OUR FIRST RESPONDERS.
IN THE LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA
SUFFERED NEARLY TEN THOUSAND
WILDFIRES HUNDREDS OF
EARTHQUAKES AND THE DOZENS OF
BLACKOUTS AND THEN THE LAST
DECADE OUR STATE HOUSING
SPRINTS AND INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF EMERGENCY SITUATIONS THAT
REQUIRE. AN INDIVIDUAL TO
PREPARE IN ADVANCE IN ENSURING
THE SAFETY OF CALIFORNIANS
DURING EMERGENCY WE SHOULD ALL
LEARN HOW TO MAKE PLANS FOR
THINGS SUCH AS ACCESS TO
SHELTER FOOD WATER BACKUP POWER
AND TRANSPORTATION FOR
OURSELVES. OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
ANIMALS ALL FIREFIGHTER DOC
EMTS PARAMEDICS POLICE OFFICERS
AND NURSES RISK THEIR LIVES
DAILY TO PROTECT CALIFORNIANS
AND WE COMMEND AND THANK THEM.
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO
PROTECTING OUR LIVES THIS
RESOLUTION JOINT AND THE
COUNTRY'S EFFORTS TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC ON HOW TO PREPARE
FOR EMERGENCIES AND THANK OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT THE
FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU MISS
RODRIGUEZ AND MR SAY ARE TO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE I'M PROUD
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES TO JOIN
AUTHOR OF THIS RESOLUTION TO
DECLARE THIS COMING MONTH OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS MONTH IN THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS HAVE
FACED OF ACCUSATIONS WILDFIRES
MUDSLIDES ROLLING BLACKOUTS IN
ELSINORE FLOWERS. DISASTERS CAN
EXPECT CONSTRUCTED ANYTIME
WITHOUT WARNING WELL OUR BRAVE
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS ARE QUICK
TO TAKE ACTION IT'S ALSO UP TO
EACH OF US TO BE PREPARED AHEAD
OF TIME HAVING A PLAN FOR
SHELTER COMMUNICATION AND
TRANSPORTATION SAVES TIME WHICH
IN TURN SAVES LIVES. IT IS MORE
CRITICAL THAN EVER BEFORE THE
CALIFORNIANS PLAN FOR EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO. SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE RESOLUTION MISTER RODRIGUEZ
WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION RECORDERS THERE
IS THE FIRST WILL BE ABLE FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON. EIGHT ZERO ONE
ONE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE
THERE SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. THIS IS SENATE-TV
THIRD PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
SIXTY FIVE AND SIXTY SIX WE'VE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE SEVENTY AND SEVENTY
ONE. THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM SEVENTY TWO S. B. FIVE
NINETY ONE. AND THE CORPORATE
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY ONE
BUYS CENTER BACKER AN ACCOLADE
IN THE CIVIL LAW IS WICKS YOU
MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
ENERGIZED INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING MODELS ADDRESS
ISOLATION AND DEPRESSION
DEPRESSION OFTEN SEEN IN
SENIORS WELL SUPPORTING
VULNERABLE YOUTH AS THEY
TRANSITION OUT OF THE FOSTER
CARE. AND ESTABLISH THEIR LIVES
INDEPENDENT ADULTS. THE CITY OF
EMERYVILLE HAS PROPOSED
INTERGENERATIONAL HOUSING
PROJECT FOR THEIR COMMUNITY
THAT IS 1100% AFFORDABLE AND
WOULD INCLUDE SIXTY EIGHT UNITS
FOR SENIORS AND TRANSITION YOU
AGE YOUTH. BUT THERE'S A
PROBLEM AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS FOR SENIORS THAT USED
TAX CREDITS WHICH IS NEARLY ALL
SUCH PROJECTS ARE PROHIBITED
FROM INCLUDING OTHER TYPES OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN THE SAME
BUILDING. DESPITE THE WELL
DOCUMENTED SOCIAL AND HEALTH
BENEFITS FOR SENIORS AND YOUTH
AFFORDABLE ENERGY INTERNET OR
INTERGENERATIONAL DEVELOPMENTS
ARE EFFECTIVELY PROHIBITED IN
CALIFORNIA. SB FIVE NINETY ONE
ALLOWS TAX CREDIT FINANCED
AFFORDABLE INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING PROJECTS PROVIDED AT
LEAST 80% OF THE UNIT UNITS ARE
OCCUPIED BY SENIOR CENTER UP
220% OF THE UNITS ARE FOR
TRANSITIONAL. AGE YOUTH THIS
BILL JOINED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
KNOWN OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB FIVE NINE ONE. THANK YOU
MISS WICKS A NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CORPORAL OF
THE ROLE OF. RESERVE OUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE GYRI
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM. SEVENTY THREE. SB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO CORKERY SENATE BILL
SEVEN SIXTY TWO BY THE CENTER
BY CAL SKI INOCULATING THE
CONTRACTS MR STILL EMAIL THE
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF CENTER
CASKET RISE TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT
PROVIDE SOME TRANSPARENCY
AROUND ARBITRATION FEES WHEN
THEY'RE TO HOW THEY GET
PROVIDED SO THAT THIS IS TO
PROTECT CUSTOMERS AND EMPLOYEES
SUBJECT TO ARBITRATION
AGREEMENTS SO THAT THEY KNOW
AND HAVE SOME CLARITY AROUND
WHEN. THE PARTY WHO IS
OBLIGATED TO PAY THE FEES DOES
OR DOESN'T PAY THOSE FEES THIS
IS A CONSUMER PROTECTION
MEASURE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SOME SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CARPAL OF THE ROLE IS OUT
OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF RESERVED
ABOUT. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR. THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE SB THREE NINETEEN CORKERY
SENATE BILL THREE NINETEEN BY
SENATOR MELENDEZ AN ACCOLADE IN
THE LAND USE MS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB THREE NINETEEN MAKES
A SIMPLE CHANGE THE MEDICATION
FIACHRA CLOSING A LITTLE PUT
LOOPHOLE RELATED TO AN REPORTS
OF THE CURRENT LAW AND AGENCY
IS OBLIGATED TO PROVIDE ANNUAL
REPORTS IDENTIFYING REVENUES
COLLECTED AND EXPANDED. AND
SPECIFIC USE OF THOSE FUNDS SB
THREE NINETEEN CORRECT THIS BY
REQUIRING AN AUDIT EACH YEAR
THE AGENCY FAILED TO PREPARE
FOR THE AGENCIES FAILED TO
PROVIDE ANNUAL REPORTS THE
SYMBOL CHANGE WILL INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY INSURE THE GENERAL
PUBLIC AND BUILDERS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW. AND
QUESTION NEW OR ADJUSTED FEES
THIS MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR MELINDA'S I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ADAM CARCLUB THE
ROLE. IT IS IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL THE TIME
ABOUT I SIXTY NINE OH ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX IS S. B. TWO NINETY
SEVEN AND THE CORPORATE SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ROSALYN ACTUALLY IN THE
SERVICE OF SUBSURFACE
INSULATIONS. MR LEVINE EMAIL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
WOULD CREATE A CIVIL PENALTY OF
UP TO ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM OPERATOR EXCAVATOR
WHO AFTER FAILING TO FOLLOW A
DIGGER ALERT REQUIREMENT
DAMAGES THE SUBSURFACE
INSULATION CAUSES THE RELEASE.
OF HAZARDOUS GAS OR LIQUID THE
BILL'S IN HONOR OF A WORKER WHO
TRAGICALLY LOST HIS LIFE WHEN A
SOLAR COMPANY FAILED TO KILL TO
CALL EIGHT ONE ONE AND DAMAGE
TO GAS LINE. SOCALGAS EMPLOYEE
WADE KILL PATRICK AND HIS CREW
WERE CALLED OUT TO FIX THE
PROBLEM AND DURING THEIR WORK
THE LEAKING GASES AND KNIGHTED
AND MR KILPATRICK WAS KILLED IN
THE EXPLOSION THIS MEASURE HAS
NO OPPOSTION RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
LEVINE SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
KARPAL ABROAD. ESERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL TYLER I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WERE TO PASS A RETAIN OF
FILE ITEM. SEVENTY SEVEN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT SB
SEVEN OH NINE CORKERY SENATE
BILL SEVEN OH NINE BY SOONER
DALLY IN ACCRA LEADING TO FORCE
THREE TO CLEAR THE RECEIVER OF
THE CORRECT IMMEDIATELY. MISSED
OUT YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN OH NINE A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MAJOR THAT
WOULD ALLOW CAL FIRE TO ALL
THREE IS A TWO YEAR EXTENSION
ON TIMBER HARVEST PLANS ARE SET
TO EXPIRE IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
OR TWENTY TWENTY TWO. CURRENTLY
TEACH PEAS ARE VALID FOR FIVE
YEARS INCOME EXTENDED FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS. COMMERCIAL
TIMBER OPERATIONS COMPLETED
UNDER TEACH FEES ARE IMPORTANT
PART OF CALIFORNIA'S FUEL
REDUCTION AND FOREST RESILIENCY
GOALS. THE MODEST EXTENSION
AUTHORIZED BY THIS BILL WILL
HELP THE STATE REACH THESE
GOALS WHILE ALSO HELPING MEET%
THE STATE'S DEMAND FOR
SUSTAINABLE WOOD PRODUCTS MOST
IMPORTANTLY. SB SEVEN OH NINE
WILL AID IN THE PREVENTION OF
MORE DEVASTATING WILDFIRES. AS
I SPEAK WERE FIGHTING THE
LARGEST WILDFIRE IN STATE
HISTORY IN MY DISTRICT. THESE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES HAVE MADE IT
NECESSARY FOR MANY TIMBER
HARVEST COMPANIES TO SHIFT
THEIR OPERATIONS TO SALVAGE
LOGGING. AND OTHER EMERGENCY
RESTORATION WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE IN THE AFTERMATH OF
THESE FIRES BY AUTHORIZING AN
ADDITIONAL TWO YEAR EXTENSION
SB SEVEN ON NINE ONE SURE THAT
LANDOWNERS CAN COMPLETE
IMPORTANT RECOVERY AND
RESTORATION WORK WITHOUT LOSING
THE ABILITY TO HIM. TO COMPLETE
ALREADY APPROVED OPERATIONS
UNDER THESE SOON TO EXPIRE
TEACH PEACE. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISSED OUT SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM THE
GLOBAL ROLE MEMBERS THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF A
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSER ALL TIED UP AND I SIXTY
KNOWS YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY
HIGHS SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE THAT BILL PASSES.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM SEVENTY
NINE THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY. SB TEN. CORKERY
SENATE BILL TEN BY CENTER
WIENER AND OTHERS AND I
RELATING TO LAND USE MR CHIU
HERE MAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT SB TEN. WHICH WOULD
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
LOCAL CONTROL WHEN IT COMES TO
BUILDING A LIGHT TOUCH MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING IF THEY SO
CHOOSE SB TEN IS A 1100%
VOLUNTARY BILL. COMPLETELY
UNDER THE CONTROL OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IF THE CITY CHOOSES
TO IMPLEMENT SB TEN THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE THAT CITY WITH AN
INEXPENSIVE AND EFFECTIVE TOOL
TO REZONE PARCELS UP TO TEN
UNITS. IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
IMPLEMENT SB TEN NOTHING WILL
CHANGE TO OPT INTO SB TEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MUST AUTHORIZE AN
ORDINANCE THAT CLEARLY SHOWS
WHICH PARCELS THEY WILL BE
REZONING. IF THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
OPT IN AGAIN NOTHING CHANGES WE
DON'T KNOW WE'RE IN THE MIDST
OF THE MOST INTENSE HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
AND THE CURRENT LAW HAS MADE IT
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR CITIES
TO REZONE. IT CAN TAKE MANY
YEARS TO COMPLETE EVEN A MODEST
REZONING COST AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND OFTEN LEAD
TO AN ENDING LITIGATION THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO AREAS THAT
ARE NEAR TRANSIT OR IN OR ARE
IN URBAN INFILL AREAS.
INCENTIVIZING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO CONCENTRATE NEW HOUSING IN
URBAN IN FILL AND TRANSIT RICH
COMMUNITIES. TO BE CLEAR. THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE HOW
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS ARE
APPROVED SB TEN ONLY APPLIES TO
THE ZONING OF THOSE PARCELS.
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS WILL STILL
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE EXISTING
PROCESS AND SEEK REVIEW. EVEN
IF IT INCLUDES A SECRET
DISCRETIONARY VIEW THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE THAT THIS BILL
HAS REAL POTENTIAL TO EMPOWER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PURSUE
MORE EQUITABLE UP ZONES. FOR
SMALL MEDIUM DENSITY
CONSTRUCTION CONSISTENT WITH
FAIR HOUSING LAW. GIVEN THAT
SEEK REVIEWS ARE OFTEN LONG
UNPREDICTABLE AND EXPENSIVE. I
HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL SUPPORT
THIS BILL AGAIN IT IS
COMPLETELY OPTIONAL. DESIGNED
TO EMPOWER CITIES TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING IN A WAY THAT IS
SUITABLE FOR THEM AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER KALRA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN WHICH IS A
SIMPLE AND VOLUNTARY HOUSING
BILLS. THAT COULD MAKE A VERY
LARGE IMPACT ON A HOUSING
SHORTAGE FOR YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS FALED TO PRODUCE ENOUGH
HOUSING TO KEEP UP WITH OUR
GROWING POPULATION. IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT WE NEED TO BUILD
BETWEEN ONE POINT EIGHT AND TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION NEW HOMES
JUST TO THE NEXT FOUR YEARS D.
EASE OUR HOUSING CRISIS TO JUST
TO MANAGEABLE LEVELS. HOWEVER
WITH MORE THAN TWO THIRDS OF
RESIDENTIAL LAND CALIFORNIA'S
OWN FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
PRODUCING THE AMOUNT OF HOUSING
NEEDED UNDER OUR CURRENT ZONING
LAWS IS NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE. SB
TEN IS A COMPLETELY OPTIONAL
BILL THAT PROVIDES CITIES WITH
THE CHOICE TO IMPLEMENT A TOOL
TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING SHORTAGE
BY ALLOWING THEM TO QUICKLY UPS
ON AN URBAN IN FILL IN TRANSIT
RICH AREAS. IN AN EFFORT TO
PRODUCE MORE SMALL UNIT MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING THE CALIFORNIA'S
LAW CALIFORNIA LACKS SB TEN
WILL GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENT A
QUICKER PATH TO REZONE SPECIFIC
PARTS OF THEIR COMMUNITIES FOR
UP TO TEN UNITS ALONG THIS
MARCH OBSERVE TO BE SHE IT'LL
SAVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
EXTENSIVE TIME MONEY AND
RESOURCES WHICH ARE ALL
EXTREMELY VALUABLE. REPRODUCING
AN INCREASED AMOUNT OF HOUSING.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO STATED THIS BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE OUT INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS ARE APPROVED. SB TEN
ONLY APPLIES TO THE REZONING OF
THESE PARCELS. INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS WILL STILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THEIR EXISTING LOCAL
APPROVING APPROVAL PROCESS.
WHICH INCLUDES AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAID IN A SEQUEL DISCRETIONARY
REVIEW OUR CITIES NEED TO
PRODUCE MORE HOUSING NOT ONLY
TO ADDRESS THE GROWING DEMAND
BUT ALSO TO MEET THEIR SIX
CYCLE REAL NUMBERS. AND I
BELIEVE IT IS THE STATE'S JOB
TO PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITH ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO DO SO
SUCCESSFULY. SB TEN HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR CITIES THAT
WANT TO USE IT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANKS
CALMEST IN YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN. THIS IS AN OPT IN TO
HOLD OUR CITIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN USE. TO BUILD
HOUSING WHERE IT IS NEEDED THE
MOST. AND MY DISTRICT IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE AUTHORIZED
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL FOR MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING NEAR BART
STATIONS. ONLY A FEW YEARS
LATER WE ARE SEEING THE GROWTH
OF VIBRANT COMMUNITY HUBS
AROUND THE STATIONS WITH
AFFORDABLE MARKET RATE AND
MIXED USE DEVELOPMENTS ALL
LOCATED WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE. OF A WORLD CLASS
TRANSIT SYSTEM. THE KIND OF
HOUSING THAT THIS BILL
ENVISIONS IS THE KIND OF
HOUSING THAT MAKES CITIES
LIVABLE AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY. EACH COMMUNITY WILL CHOOSE
WHETHER THEY TAKE WHETHER THEY
WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
PROVISIONS ARE NOT. WE
REGULARLY PASS BILLS HOUSING
BILLS THAT ASK A LOT OF OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LET'S PASS
THIS BILL TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
THE ABILITY TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES. HOW THEY WANT TO
SHAPE THEIR COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I'VE
THANKS GRAYSON MISS WICKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SAN FRANCISCO
SAN JOSE IN CONCORD. HAVE
ARTICULATED WHY I'M A SUPPORTER
OF THIS BILL AS A CO AUTHOR I
STRONGLY URGE AN AYE VOTE. THIS
BILL IS VOLUNTARY IT EMPOWERS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO TAKE THE
ISSUE INTO THEIR OWN HANDS IN
THE WAY THAT THEY CHOOSE TO.
AND WHAT IT DOES MOST
IMPORTANTLY IS THAT CAN LEAD TO
MORE PRODUCTION OF THAT MISSING
MIDDLE HOUSING THAT WE NEED SO
DESPERATELY I HAVE TEACHERS
AND- NURSES IN MY DISTRICT THAT
ARE DRIVING FOUR HOURS ROUND
TRIP. EVERY SINGLE DAY TO GO TO
WORK. IT'S NOT HEALTHY FOR THEM
IT'S NOT HEALTHY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
OUR ENVIRONMENT. WHEN THEY'RE
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME ON THE
ROAD SO IN THESE URBAN AREAS WE
NEED MORE TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS NEEDED.
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WICKS SAYING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM MR CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WANT TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUES
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT YOU MENTION IT
AGAIN TO SUMMARIZE THIS IS A
BILL ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL IT IS
OPTIONAL AND VOLUNTARY IT'S
ABOUT EMPOWERING CITIES IT'S
ABOUT ENSURING THAT WE USE A
LIGHT TOUCH FOR MODEST REZONING
OF SMALL SCALE COMMUNITIES AND
WITH THAT IN THE MIDST OF THE
MOST INTENSE HOUSING CRISIS
OURS STATE HAS EXPERIENCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CHIU AT THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER DESIRED
ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY ONE
KNOWS NINE. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK IN
THE FILE TO TAKE MS FRIEDMAN
THIS ITEM THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT SB SEVENTY ONE AND A
CORPORATE SENATE BILL SEVENTY
ONE BY SENATE MCGUIRE AND
ACTUALLY THE CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
MISS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SEVENTY ONE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
JUDGES THE OPTION TO USE PROVEN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AS A
COMMUNITY SERVICE OPTION TO
PAYING INFRACTION FINES AND
FEES. CALIFORNIA'S TRAFFIC
FINES AND FEES ARE SOME OF THE
HIGHEST IN THE COUNTRY
CURRENTLY JUDGES WHO WERE
ALLOWED TO PRIVATE PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT OPTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD FACE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP IN PAYING
THE MANDATED TRAFFIC FEES.
OPTIONS MAY INCLUDE PAYING IN
INSTALLMENTS OR COMPLETE
COMMUNITY CERTAIN COMPLETING
COMMUNITY SERVICE HOURS IN LIEU
FOR THE TOTAL FINE THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE OPTION WHICH
IS INTENDED TO AID LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. CAN BECOME
INACCESSIBLE IF THE HOURS ARE
TOO STEEP FOR WORKING PEOPLE
ARE PEOPLE TAKING CARE OF
CHILDREN I CAN HINDER SOMEONE'S
ABILITY TO MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT
ATTEND SCHOOL OR CARE FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS. SB SEVENTY ONE
WERE HELP DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES FOR PHIL FINANCIAL
OBLIGATION TO THE COURT BY
EXPANDING THE COMMUNITY SERVICE
OPTION TO OFFER ACCESS TO
VALUABLE EDUCATION OPPORTUNE.
OPPORTUNITIES EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS MIGHT INCLUDE HIGH
SCHOOL OR GENERAL EDUCATION
DEVELOPMENT CLASSES COLLEGE
COURSES ADULT LITERACY OR
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS VOCATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS SB SAID BRITNEY ONE
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IS NO OPPOSITION. AND I REQUEST
FULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN. SAY
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. LOCAL OF THE ROLE MEMBERS
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF. DESIRABLE. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I FIFTY SIX NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN
REGULAR FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY ONE. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE
CORKERY SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
FIVE BY SERIAL CHOKO AND
ACCORDING TO TAXATION MISTER
MASON MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB SIX ANY FIVE
WOULD SIMPLY GIVE COUNTIES THE
OPTION TO IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM
TO ALLOW TAXPAYERS WHO ARE
OVERSEAS DID HERE'S OLD OR WHO
RECEIVE SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY
INCOME TO PAY THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES IN MONTHLY INSTALLMENTS
RATHER THAN INTO LUMP SUMS.
THIS WOULD BE A VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM FOR BOTH THE COUNTY AND
THE TAXPAYER UNDER EXISTING LAW
PROPERTY TAXES ARE PAID INTO
ANNUAL INSTALLMENTS THIS IS
PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT FOR
TAXPAYERS RELY ON FIXED INCOMES
AND TAXPAYERS WHO RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL SECURITY INCOME
FOR DISABILITY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
REST SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE
CARCLUB. IT IS OUT OF IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO. SB FIVE
OH SEVEN CORKERY SENATE BILL
FIVE OH SEVEN BY SERVER ADMIN
AND OTHERS AND I PUT IN IT
MENTAL HEALTH MS CLARK SILVA
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
FIVE ZERO SEVEN AUTHORED BY
SENATOR EGGMAN WHICH WILL MAKE
REVISIONS TO LAURA'S LAW
ROUGHLY ONE IN FOUR PEOPLE
PLACED ON CONSERVATORSHIP CYCLE
BACK TO RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO QUALIFY
FOR ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT A. O. T. A PERSON'S
CONDITION MUST BE SUBSTANTIALLY
DETERIORATING. AND ESSENCE
GETTING WORSE THIS CRITERIA
ESSENTIALLY PROHIBITS THOSE
EXITING MORE RESTRICTIVE
TREATMENT SETTINGS FROM
ACCESSING ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY
BENEFIT FROM THE SERVICES
FRIENDS WE KNOW THAT MANY OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WE WANT TO SEE
GET TREATMENT. THEY ARE ON OUR
STREETS AND THIS BILL WILL HELP
THEM GET TREATMENT SB FIVE ZERO
SEVEN ENSURES THAT COUNTIES
WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER AND
DELIVER ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THAT WILL
PROVIDE CONTINUED TREATMENT AND
ACCESS. AND RESOURCES THIS BILL
PASSED OUT OF HEALTH AND
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES IN BOTH
HOUSES WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA C. NOTICE CASH REBATE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL WHAT
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
THE DESIRABLE. YEAH. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE S. B. TWO SEVENTY FOUR
FOR COREY SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY FOUR BY CENTER BY CAL
SKI IN AFTER LEAVING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MS RIVAS YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR IS A SIMPLE
BUT IMPORTANT BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW CONSTITUENTS TO RECEIVE
AGENDA PACKETS FROM THEIR LOCAL
AGENCIES BY EMAIL. CURRENTLY
THE BROWN ACT ONLY REQUIRES
LOCAL AGENCIES TO MAIL AGENDA
PACKETS. WHICH MEANS SOMETIMES
DOCUMENTS ARE DELIVERED AFTER
MEETINGS HAVE CONCLUDED. SB TWO
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD FIX THAT BY
ALLOWING A FASTER EASIER AND
MORE EFFICIENT METHOD FOR BOTH
THE GOVERNING BODIES AND
CONSTITUENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS RIVAS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE OUT
OF CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IS
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRABLE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS
EIGHTY FOUR THROUGH EIGHTY SIX
PASSED RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SEVEN. SENATE BILL TWO
NINE TO OPERATE. SENATE BILL
TWO NINETY TWO BY CENTER WILK
AND OTHERS AND ACCOLADES
WINDOWS WERE HOME. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER SPEAKER I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB TWO NINE TWO ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR SCOTT WILK
REGARDING INDUSTRIAL HEMP. THE
TWO EIGHTEEN FARM BUILDING
ALLIES THE FARMING OF HEMP AS
AN AGRICULTURAL COMMODITY.
UNDER SECTION TEN ELEVEN
THIRTEEN OF THE BILL OF THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
MUST CONSULT WITH THE STATE'S
GOVERNOR AND CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER TO DEVISE A
PLAN TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE
SECRETARY. OF THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE
ULTIMATELY THE FARM BILL
LEGALIZE HIM BUT IT DID NOT
CREATE A SYSTEM TO GROW IT AS
FREELY AS OTHER CROPS AS HIM IS
A HIGHLY REGULATED- CROP IN THE
UNITED STATES FOR BOTH PERSONAL
INDUSTRIAL PRODUCTION.
LEGISLATION WAS THEREFORE
NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA CONFORM
TO THE NEW REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THE FARM BILL THAT LEGISLATION
CAME IN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY
THREE AGAIN BY SENATOR WORLD.
FOR WHICH I WAS A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE OF
THE SP ONE FIFTY EIGHT IN
OCTOBER TWO NINE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN USDA PUBLISHED THIS
MONTH. ANTICIPATED INTRAMURAL
REGARDING HIM CULTIVATION
INCLUDING ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS
FOR THE NEEDED TO BE REFLECTED
IN THE CALIFORNIA FOOD NEVER
CULTURE CODE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. REGULATIONS IN
STATE PLAN I'M NOT THEM THE
NEAREST IS SUBSEQUENTLY
APPROVED THIS FINAL RULE WHICH
TOOK EFFECT ON MARCH TWENTIETH
TWO OF THIS YEAR AND
INCORPORATES MODIFICATIONS THE
REGULATIONS ESTABLISHED UNDER
THE INTERIM ROLE THAT ARE BASED
ON PUBLIC COMMENTS FOLLOWING
THE PUBLICATION OF THE RULE AND
LESSONS LEARNED DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY GROWING SEASON SB
TWO NINE TWO IS A FOLLOW UP
FROM FIFTY ONE FIFTY THREE TO
CONFORM WITH THESE MORE
SPECIFIC ISSUES APPROVED BY
USDA. AND THERE ARE EFFORT IN
THE FINAL RULE THIS MEASURE HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND AS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THEREFORE I
ASKED BUT I VOTE FOR MYSELF AND
SENATOR WILL. THANK AN EXECUTOR
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF RESERVE A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARABLE. THANK
WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY EIGHT THROUGH
NINETY WE'VE DISPENSED WITH
FILE ITEM NINETY ONE PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS NINETY TWO.
THROUGH. NINETY SIX. IT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN SB
TWO NINETY CORPORATE SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY BY CENTER
SKINNER AND ALKYLATING TO
HOUSING MS CLARK SILVA THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT SB TWO NINETY WHICH
IS AUTHORED BY SENATOR SKINNER
SB TWO NINETY UPDATES
CALIFORNIA'S DENSITY BONUS LAW
IT ALLOWS A DEVELOPERTO GET UP
TO ONE INCENTIVE IF 20% OF
UNITS ARE FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS CONFORMS DENSITY BONUS
APPROVAL PROCESS TO
REQUIREMENTS IN THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT EXPANDS
DEFINITION OF FOR SALE PROJECTS
BEYOND COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS INCLUDING UNITS
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND IT
ADDS A PARKING WAIVER RELATED
TO FOR SALE PROJECTS THAT ARE
WITHIN A HALF MILE OF TRANSIT.
AND INCLUDE 40% MODERATE INCOME
UNITSMEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK REST
WORKS OVER CENA DISCUSSION
DEBATE LOCAL OF THE ROLE. IS
THERE A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CULTURAL TIE VOTE ICE FIFTY
EIGHT KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE.
I ITEM WHAT A ONE. SB TWO
THIRTY NINE CORKERY SENATE BILL
TWO THIRTY NINE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS NOT
COMMITTING THE GOVERNMENT
FINANCE MISTER GRAYSON YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB TWO THIRTY NINE IS
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BANKING
AND FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
COMMITTEE BILL IT PROVIDES THE
STATE TREASURER WITH ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO MANAGE FUNDS IN
A WAY THAT SAFEGUARDS TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND MAINTAINS ADEQUATE
LIQUIDITY RECENT AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL NATURED NON
SUBSTANTIVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHENEVER. THANK MISS GRAYSON C.
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WHAT IS
THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELLURIDE'S SIXTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS ONE OF TWO THROUGH ONE OF
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS A MEMBER WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING AND HEARING
NONE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE WAS
LUCIEN EIGHT BY CELEBRATORY
RELATIVE TO THOSE AND CHIANG HO
DAY THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE UP AT IS SIXTY
SIX. NOES ZERO. CONSENT
CALENDARS ADOPTED FOR POOR READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HOUSE WAS
LUCIEN SEVENTEEN I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO CONSTITUTION THIRTY FIVE I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SAN HOUSE
RESOLUTION. FIFTY SEVEN FIVE
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS FOR
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MR COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES IT IS MY HONOR TODAY
TO RISE I REQUEST THAT THIS
HOUSE ADJOURN IN MEMORY A RANDY
PARA GEHRY A PIONEER IN
SACRAMENTO'S NIGHTLIFE AND
DINING SCENE AND THOSE OF YOU
ON THE FLOOR I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE HE
DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO HOSPITALITY
WE'RE JOINED TODAY BY HIS WIFE
STACEY HIS SON SAM HIS DAUGHTER
LISA SO I THANK YOU FOR THIS
CONFERMENT OF HOSPITALITY TO
THE SACRAMENTO'S WHO MADE SUCH
A DIFFERENCE. AND WHEN I SAY HE
WAS A PIONEER OF THE DINING
SCENE IT'S ALMOST- I NEED TO
POINT OUT THAT IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THERE WAS NOT A
RESTAURANT SCENE IN SACRAMENTO.
YES FRANK FAT'S WAS HERE
BRANDON'S WAS HERE THE BROILER
WERE HERE THERE WERE PLACE IN
TOWN BUT THE CONCEPT OF A
DINING SCENE A RESTAURANTS YOU
TO SACRAMENTO WHAT HAVE BEEN
FORMED IN THE SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES IN THE EIGHTIES THIS
IS A MAN WHO BY HIS DEVOTION TO
HIS CRAFT AND THIS COMMUNITY
FOR HE GREW UP IN SACRAMENTO
AND STATE IN SACRAMENTO HAD A
TRANSFORMATIVE INFLUENCE ON THE
DOWNTOWN I REMEMBER WHEN THE
CASE TREAT MALL WAS A WASTELAND
WHEN J. STREET WAS A WASTELAND
WHEN THERE WAS JUST NOT
ACTIVITY IN THE DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO THE OLD COW TOWN ON
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS LIKE WHEN
RANDY PARA GEHRY DETERMINED
THAT HE WOULD TRY TO ENGAGE IN
HOSPITALITY AND I POINT THIS
OUT BECAUSE IT'S SO EASY TO
ENJOY THE NIGHTLIFE IN
SACRAMENTO TODAY THE RESTAURANT
SCENE BUT I JUST WANTED TO GO
BACK FORTY YEARS FIFTY YEARS
AND THINK ABOUT THE QUALITIES
OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
DETERMINE THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO PURSUE A WORK IN RESTAURANTS
HOSPITALITY IT'S LIKE YOU KNOW
YOU IT TAKES INCREDIBLE VISION
PERSISTENCE INDUSTRY UNFLAGGING
DEVOTION YOU KNOW CLIMB A
DIFFICULT HILL I THINK OF READY
PLAYER VERY ENTERS THE BUILDING
ACROSS THE STREET FROM US WILL
BE ONE BRING ME PEOPLE IT SAYS
IT DOES SAY MAN TO MATCH MY
MOUNTAINS YOU WERE A PIONEER
CALIFORNIA COME OF THOSE
MOUNTAINS WILL ACCEPT WITH
EXTRAORDINARY. HOPE HARD WORK.
EVERY DAY A RENEWED EFFORT USE
YOUR TIME WELL TO GO OVER THE
MOST ALL THESE QUALITIES. WE
SEE IN RANDY PARA GARY RANDY
PASSED AWAY ON AUGUST
THIRTEENTH OF THIS YEAR. AT THE
AGE OF SEVENTY FOUR. HE HD A
VERY HARD FOUGHT BATTLE WITH
CANCER. HE WAS BORN ON NOVEMBER
EIGHTH NINETEEN FORTY SIX. HE
WOULD GRADUATE ADVENTURE FROM
C. K. MCCLATCHY HIGH SCHOOL
HERE IN SACRAMENTO THEN THEY HE
WENT ON TO SEVERAL STATE AND MY
ALARM MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF LAW HE
IS A GRADUATE ALSO BRIEF GEORGE
SO HE PROCEED TO BE THERE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY DIE READY PER
VERY FOUND HIS CALLING AND
HOSPITALITY OPENED HIS VERY
FIRST LIVE MUSIC CLUB OF THE
PARA PARA PALACE A SALOON ON
THIRTIETH AND- STREETS. AND HE
WELCOMED IN THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
OF THAT ERA THAT CAME WITH
THEIR LONG HAIR ONE TO LISTEN
TO THE MUSIC AND ENJOY GOOD
TIMES IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
HE TOOK ON A NEW BUSINESS
VENTURE THAT WOULD BECOME THE
BACKBONE OF HIS SUCCESS. AND
REALLY SET THE STAGE FOR THE
REINVENTION OF RESTAURANT IN IN
SACRAMENTO. LOCATED ON TWENTY
EIGHT AND THEN STREETS
FREQUENTED BY FORMER SPEAKER
WILLIE BROWN. WHO WOULD HOLD
COURT THERE RANDY ESTABLISHED
THE FAMOUS PARA GARY'S
RESTAURANT IT WAS SUCH A
SUCCESS AND BECAME A MODEL FOR
CAFE BERNARDO CENTRAL KATRINA
MEXICANA READ A TERROR WAS VERY
DEVOTED TO HIS HOME CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND BULLISH ON HIS
FUTURE AND NEVER NEVER FLAG HE
JUST KEPT AWAY WORKING AWAY AT
IT. HE WAS ALWAYS INTERESTED IN
NEW BUSINESS VENTURES AND THEY
ALSO. OF I LEFT A LEGACY THAT
IS BEYOND THE RESTAURANTS
BEHIND HE CERTAINLY BELIEVED IN
BEING AN ENTREPRENEUR AND
ENCOURAGED HIS EMPLOYEES TO
BRANCH OUT AND TO GROW AND
DEVELOP AND- HE PARTNER WITH
SOME OF HIS MOST AMBITIOUS
EMPLOYEES IN THE RESTAURANT
BUSINESS HE ACHIEVES SUCCESS
AND I REMIND YOU STARTING FROM
THE DARK DANK EARLY DAYS OF
SACRAMENTO WAS DIDN'T HAVE A
RESTAURANT SCENE THROUGH THIS
GREAT PERSEVERANCE R. BRIAN
FUSING HIS BRILLIANCE PASSION
AND EXUBERANCE INTO HIS WORK HE
LOVED PEOPLE AND RANDY
PEREGRINE NEVER MISSED A MOLD
TO ENJOY TO ITS UTMOST GOOD
COMPANY LAUGHTER AND MEMORY
MAKING SHORTLY BEFORE HIS DEATH
THE VISIONARY BENT THE RANDY
PAIR GROCERS SILVA NEW. AS HE
LED IN THE START UP OF A NEW
KIND OF HOSPITALITY BUSINESS
THEY NEVER UNDERTAKEN BEFORE.
HOTELS HIS FOR CHARTER HOTEL AT
TWENTY EIGHT AND. ON TWENTY
EIGHTH STREET OPENED LAST YEAR
LEAVE NO DOUBT THE RANDY PAIR
REYES VISION AND IMAGINATION
WAS ON FLAG TODAY THE CENTRAL
REGION HAS BECOME A HAVEN FOR
CHEFS AND FARTHER FOR CUISINE A
TREMENDOUS PART OF SAKARA LIFE
TO EVERY MEMBER OF THIS BODY
ENJOYS ACTUALLY. THAT RANDY
PARA GEHRY WAS THE PIONEER OF
INSTANCE SET THAT BALL ROLLING
YOU KNOW IT SAYS OF LIFE RALPH
WALDO EMERSON SAID INSTITUTIONS
LINKED IN SHADOW OF ONE PERSON.
SENATE YOU MIGHT LOOK AT
SOMEONE'S LIFE AND SAY WELL
OVER THE COURSE OF THEIR LIFE
BE ACHIEVED A GREAT DEAL THEY
JUST SHOWED A LONG PERSISTENCE
IN THE SAME DIRECTION YOU KNOW
THIS POWER OF PERSISTENCE OF
JUST STAYING THE COURSE KEEPING
MATTER HE DID GO TO LAW SCHOOL
BUT HE DETERMINED THAT THE
HOSPITALITY BUSINESS THE WORST
PART WAS AND HE POURED HIMSELF
INTO IT AND TRANSFORM
SACRAMENTO. HE AUTOGRAPHED HIS
WORK WITH QUALITY ALL OF THESE
THINGS WE ARE SOCIAL GREATNESS
YOU SEE IT READY PARA HERE SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY- OUR JOURNEY IN HIS
MEMORY THIS INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD
A TRANSFORMATIVE AFFECT ON
SACRAMENTO ON THE QUALITY OF
LIFE OF MEMBERS EXPERTS FEAR SO
FAR FROM HOME HE TOUCHED EACH
ONE OF US AND HE DID IT WITH
GREAT GRACE AND WELCOME MANAGE
JUST TOUCHING PEOPLE'S LIVES
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T SIXTEEN THIS
BUSINESS WITHOUT EVERYONE
UNIFORMLY FINDING THAT TO
ENCOUNTER YOU IN YOUR WORK AND
WHAT YOU ESTABLISH WAS GOOD FOR
THEM SO WHAT A WHAT A
TREMENDOUS LEGACY OF RANDY PARA
VERY AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY JOURNALISM HONOR
TODAY. THANK YOU MISS COOLEY
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE STREET GERMAN
MEMORY. MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
MY HEART IS HEAVY TODAY AS I
RISE TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES TO
SAY GOODBYE TO MY FRIEND RANDY
PERRY JERRY I MET RANDY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE WHEN I WAS
HIRED AS A WAITRESS AT PERRY
GERRY'S HE WAS SITTING IN MY
SECTION SO I NERVOUSLY
APPROACHED AND ASKED IF HE
WOULD LIKE A DRINK WHAT'S YOUR
NAME PASSED. LISA I SAID. HE
SMILED EAR TO EAR. THAT'S MY
DAUGHTER'S NAME HE SAID IN
ORDER TO THE COOPER LIBRA. I
POLITELY WALKED AWAY AND WENT
BACK TO THE BAR TO ASK WHAT IF-
BELIEVER WEST THE BARTENDER
SMILED AND SAID HE COULD HAVE
JUST ORDERED A RUMAND COKE
HE'S MESSING WITH YOU I LOOKED
BACK AND HE WAS GRINNING AS AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND MEMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY RANDY WAS
AN ICON MANY OF US NATIVE
SACRAMENTO AND WE'RE JUST SIX
DEGREES OF SEPARATION FROM HIM
YOU MAY HAVE READ ABOUT THE
PEOPLE SAT ON THEIR LIFE FOR
BUSINESS PATH. IN A WAY
CONNECTED TO RANDY FROM THE
TIME I SERVED HIM A COOPER
LIBRA RANDY INFLUENCED IN SOME
WAY MY PERSONAL CAREER PATH AT
PERRY GERRY'S I MET A POLITICAL
MENTOR THAT WOULD START ME ON
MY POLITICAL JOURNEY A FUTURE
EMPLOYER THAT WOULD START ME ON
A TWENTY FIVE YEAR CAREER IN
ENERGY AND THE LOVE OF MY LIFE
THAT IS I MET SPEAKER WILLIE
BROWN JUNIOR THE FUTURE
PRESIDENT OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON BOB FOSTER
AND MY HUSBAND CHUCK RANDY LOVE
PEOPLE AND WASN'T AFRAID TO
SHOW IT. HE WAS A GOOD
LISTENER. AND GENERALLY
INTERESTED IN WHATEVER PEOPLE
HAD TO SHARE TO THIS DAY I
CAN'T TELL YOU A FRIEND HE WAS
A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN BUT HE
PARTICULARLY LOVED AND
RESPECTED LEGISLATORS AND OTHER
POLITICAL PEOPLE MANY TIMES
MEMBERS WOULD COME INTO THE
RESTAURANT LATE AND ALONE
POLITICS CAN BE A LONELY
BUSINESS RANDY WOULD ALWAYS SIT
AND TALK WITH THEM HE KEPT
THEIR CONFIDENCE AND HE WAS
PROTECTIVE OF THEM. PEOPLE
ALWAYS FEEL GOOD WHEN RANDY WAS
AROUND HE WAS A DEVOTED HUSBAND
PROUD FATHER AND LOYAL FRIEND I
CAN REMEMBER WHEN STACEY FIRST
WALKED INTO PERRY KERRY'S
RANDY'S HOLDEN MEANER CHANGED
SHE WAS A CALMING FORCE AND
GAVE HIM BALANCE. STACEY
BROUGHT OUT THE BEST IN HIM
RANDY LEFT HIS CHILDREN LISA
AND SAM I REMEMBER THE SUMMERS
WE NEVER WORRIED OF SOMEONE
FAILED TO SHOW UP FOR SHIFT
BECAUSE RANDY RICHEST ATHLETES
AT A FELON SHE WAS ALWAYS THERE
TO HELP AND RANDY ADORED HER HE
FELT NO LESS FOR SAM WHEN I
FIRST WALKED INTO THE FORTY
THIRD CENTER HOTEL EARLIER THIS
YEAR I BUMPED INTO RANDY AS WE
ARE CATCHING UP ON OUR FAMILIES
HE TOLD ME HOW PROUD HE WAS.
THE SAM WAS GOING TO UC
BERKELEY AND THAT THE ONE
SILVER LINING OF COVE IT WAS
THAT HE GOT TO SPEND MORE TIME
WITH HIS SON. THE LAST TIME I
SAW RANDY WITH THAT THE FOURTH
LETTER HOTEL HE WAS WITH STACY
I WAS ON MY WAY TO AREAS. TO
ATTEND WOMEN'S CAUCUS EVENT FOR
THE FIRST PARTNER RANDY
MENTIONED THAT HE HAD NEVER
MATTER AND I TOLD THEM I HAD
MATTER EITHER SO I SAID WHY
DON'T WE WALK OVER A METER
TOGETHER I REMEMBER HE SHE WAS
EQUALLY EXCITED TO MEET HIM
BECAUSE SHE TALKED TO HER FOR
ABOUT TEN MINUTES AND HE JUST
LOOKS SO HAPPY YOU KNOW HE WAS
REALLY IN HIS ELEMENT. AND
THAT'S THE WAY I WANT TO
REMEMBER HIM. IT'S HARD FOR
SACRAMENTO TO THINK OF
SACRAMENTO. WITHOUT THINKING OF
RANDY PERIOD. RANDY HAS ALSO
LEFT HIS MARK ON CALIFORNIA
WELL THERE WAS A COMPANY HE
SHARED WITH THOSE WHO FOUND
THEIR WAY TO HIS DOORS OR THE
POLICY THAT WAS MADE OVER
DINNER IS. SERVED ON HIS TABLE
TOPS OR THE POLITICAL EVENTS
HOSTED AT ITS RESTAURANTS HE
WAS PART OF THE FABRIC THE
NURTURE CHANGE IN THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN MY
COLLEAGUES INTO TURNING AND
MEMORY OF A GREAT CALIFORNIA
RANDY PERRY ARE. THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON. M. MISTER
COOPER YOU TWO ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THE SHERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
BLOOD TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
READY PARA GEHRY A LONGTIME
RESTAURANTEUR AND PIONEER OF
GOOD FOOD NIGHTLIFE IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA. I THE PLEASURE
OF KNOWING RANDY HIS WIFE STACY
HIS DAUGHTER LISA AND SON SAM I
LOST ALREADY PROBABLY ABOUT
THREE MONTHS AGO AT THE FOR
SUTTER I WAS THERE FOR DINNER
AT CAFE BERNARDO AND HE WAS
THERE BUT RANDY STACY AND SAM
EATING DINNER- SAT DOWN TALKING
FOR ABOUT A HALF HOUR EMPIRE TO
FORCE THAT ARE BEING BUILT FOR
THE PAST TWO YEARS. THERE TWICE
ALREADY IN ST YOU TALKED ABOUT
HOW PROUD HE WAS EXCITED HE WAS
TO BUILD THE HOTEL IS NOW
STANDING HOTEL YOU KNOW READY
TO THE KIND OF. KIND OF PERSON
THAT WAS PASSIONATE. WHO CARE
DEEPLY ABOUT HIS COMMUNITY.
BESIDES RESTAURANTS BEING
PHENOMENAL. HIS RESTAURANTS
TOUCHED LIVES OF HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE. CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING CHEFS AND RESTAURANT
WORKERS HAVE GONE ON TO OPEN
THEIR OWN RESTAURANTS ANY OF
THE SPECIAL MAN IN THE MINUTE
IS PLACED IN SACRAMENTO HISTORY
HE LET HIS FAMILY VERY DEARLY
READY WE TRULY MISSED BUT NEVER
FORGOTTEN THANK YOU OR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF READY PLAYER GARY
THANK YOU MISS COOPER AND MR
COOLEY YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FAMILY WHO IS
HERE TODAY AND THEIR GUESTS WE
HAVE. HIS WIFE STACY HIS
DAUGHTER LISA HIS SON SAM OF
APPEAR ABOVE THE ALSO FRIEND
STEVEN RENDELL OF MARKSTEIN ARE
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS TODAY AND
TO THE FAMILY I WANT TO SAY-
BECAUSE YOU LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
YOU'LL ALWAYS HEAR THE PHRASE
RIVER CITY AND I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU THAT WHEN YOU HEAR THE
PHRASE RIVER CITY THINK OF THE
WAY IN WHICH RANDY CARP A
CHANNEL. THROUGH THIS TOWN LEFT
HIS MARK. YOU KNOW IT IS SAID
OF RIVERS THAT A RIVER CUTS
THROUGH ROCK NOT BY POWER BUT
BECAUSE OF ITS PERSISTENCE AND
HERE IN RIVER CITY- THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT READY PLAYER JERRY
DID HE CUT HIS WAY THROUGH THIS
LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK IT IS A
GREAT LEGACY- BUT WE ARE VERY
SAD I JOIN YOU IN YOUR LOSS
TODAY. AND I DO A PROCEDURE IN
THEIR MEMORY THERE WAS COOLEY
THANK YOU MEMBERS. MR LACKEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO JOURNAL MEMORY OF
OFFICER JEREMIAH HART A
PERSONAL FRIEND. AND A FELLOW
CHP OFFICER GERMAN I GREW UP IN
L. VALINE ATTENDED QUARTZ HILL
HIGH SCHOOL GROWING UP HE
DEVELOPED A PASSION FOR
ENGINEERING. MECHANICS AND HAD
MANY PROJECT VEHICLES HE LATER
MOVED TO FLORIDA. AND WORKED AS
A SYSTEMS ANALYST LATER
RETURNING THE OTTAWA VALLEY TO
SERVE AS A CHP OFFICER. FOR
TWELVE YEARS HE WAS ONLY FORTY
FOUR YEARS OLD HE PASSED AWAY
LAST WEEK AS I WAITED IN THE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT WHEN HE
WASN'T WORKING HE WAS ENJOYING
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY INCLUDING
ANNUAL TRIPS TO BASS LAKE HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE CYNTHIA
HIS CHILDREN TIMOTHY COURTNEY
AND EZEKIEL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASKED WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF OFFICER JEREMIAH HART. THANK
YOU S. LAGGING YEAH MISTER
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST TODAY
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF MICHAEL JESTER WHO
TRAGICALLY PASSED AWAY ON JULY
TWENTY FOURTH. AT THE AGE OF
FORTY FIVE FOLLOWING A FOUR
YEAR BATTLE WITH ESOPHAGEAL
CANCER MICHAEL WAS A BELOVED
LEADER IN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
USING HIS EXCEPTIONAL ENERGY
TALENT AND IRRESISTIBLE WARMTH
TO NURTURE AND GROW NUMEROUS
JEWISH COMMUNAL INSTITUTIONS UP
AND DOWN THE WEST COAST MOST
RECENTLY MICHAEL SERVED AS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE JEWISH
FEDERATION OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
WHERE HE CHAMPIONED INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS THAT IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF COUNTLESS INDIVIDUALS AROUND
THE GLOBE MIKE ALSO SERVED IN
SENIOR EXECUTIVE ROLES AT THE
JEWISH FEDERATION OF GREATER
PORTLAND THE JEWISH FEDERATION
OF GREATER LOS ANGELES AND USC
HELLO. AND VERY ABLY SERVED AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
JEWISH WORLD WATCH A NONPROFIT
COMMITTED TO FIGHTING GENOCIDE
AND MASS ATROCITIES
HEADQUARTERED IN MIGHT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT IN THE WEST SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY A TALENTED
FUNDRAISER MICHAEL HELPED RAISE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO FUND
PROGRAMS THAT CHANGE THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE IN LOCATIONS AS
DIVERSE AS SAN DIEGO. LOS
ANGELES PORTLAND ISRAEL
BULGARIA RUSSIA THE SUDAN AND
THE DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC OF THE
CONGO MERE WEEKS BEFORE HIS
PASSING MICHAEL WAS AWARDED THE
PRESTIGIOUS SHEA ROUTE LET ON
AWARD FROM HEBREW UNION COLLEGE
JEWISH INSTITUTE OF RELIGION
ACCORDING TO ERIC LUDWIG
DIRECTOR OF THE ZELKO SCHOOL OF
JEWISH NONPROFIT MANAGEMENT THE
AWARD WAS WELL DESERVED
RECOGNITION. OF MICHAEL'S
EXAMPLE IS SERVICE TO THE
JEWISH PEOPLE THE PROFESSIONAL
ACHIEVEMENTS THE FRIENDSHIPS
AND THE QUIET REPAIR OF A
BROKEN WORLD ARE TESTAMENT TO
THE SACRED INTENTION OF
MICHAEL'S LEADERSHIP AND HIS
GIFT TO FUTURE GENERATIONS AND
REFLECTING ON MICHAEL'S LIFE
AND LEGACY AND THE TIME THAT WE
SPENT TOGETHER DURING HIS YEARS
IN LOS ANGELES I WAS REMINDED
OF A FAVORITE TEACHING FROM A
JEWISH ETHICAL TAX NOTICE PAYER
CALVET. WITCHES VISORS IT IS
NOT OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
FINISH THE WORK OF PERFECTING
THE WORLD BUT NEITHER ARE WE
FREE TO DESIST FROM IT
MICHAEL'S LIFE REFLECTED THAT
WISDOM AND HE LEAVES BEHIND AN
EXTRAORDINARY LEGACY OF SERVICE
FRENSHIP PASSION AND
COMPASSION. THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO INSPIRE ALL WHO ARE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE KNOWN HIM
MICHAEL IS SURVIVED BY FAMILY
AND EXTENDED COMMUNITY OF
FRIENDS AND ADMIRERS WHO WILL
MISS HIM DEEPLY INCLUDING HIS
WIFE LAURA. THIS FOUR YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER ELEANOR PARENTS FAYE
AND PAUL JUST SIR. HIS BROTHERS
MARK AND DAVE AND COUNTLESS
FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES FROM
AROUND THE WORLD MICHAEL JESTER
WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED BUT HIS
MEMORY WILL BE A BLESSING TO
CALIFORNIA TO ISRAEL INTO THE
GLOBAL JEWISH. COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE WE
JOINED TODAY IN HIS MEMORY.
DAVIS GABRIEL THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE READ THE NAMES OF THE
DESI PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED. IN THE JOURNAL. I
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
THERE WILL BE A JOINT HEARING
OF WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE AND
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEES IN THIS
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER. THIRTY
MINUTES AFTER WE ADJOURN
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY AUGUST TWENTY FOUR
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
AUGUST TWENTY FIFTH CHEK IN
SESSION THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY
SIX. FLOOR SESSIONS AT NINE AM
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN IS REYES MOVES AND
MISTER FLORA SECOND SET THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH.
AT NINE AM AND THE QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED.
FILE FIFTY SIX BILL
AB EIGHT OH THREE BIGELOW I TO
NOT VOTING. MODE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT OH THREE I
TO NOT VOTING.